I'll just go to saaks on this one saaks
what is your take at this point with the
resignations and then this power moved
by
Satia in terms of what unprecedented
nature of this value destruction take it
where you want to go well yeah I think
it is unprecedented um I mean it's not
unprecedented for a Founder CEO to be
fired by a board I mean that does happen
nobody likes it but it does occasionally
happen however it only happens when a is
in crisis and things have gone off the
rails or there's some sort of criminal
misconduct it takes you know something
really egregious uh to get a Founder CEO
fired and here not only do we not have
that I mean open AI was on a trajectory
to be one of the next great companies of
Silicon Valley I mean it was I guess
they were working on a 90 billion
financing round um up from 30 just a
short while ago if you had asked most
people in Silicon Valley what the next
trillion dollar software company was
likely to be I think everybody would
have said open AI I mean it was one of
those companies like a Google like a
Microsoft like a you know Facebook or
meta where um you know they had
basically figured out something very
fundamental they had engineered the next
kind of Technology platform shift and so
open AI was one of those generational
companies and so and everything was calm
everything was working I mean this is a
on top of its game and a Founder
apparently who was at the top of his
game and so I think this kind of came
out of the blue on Friday and so when
they put out that announcement on Friday
saying that Sam hadn't been candid which
as far as these things go was a very um
you know that that was a pretty harsh
statement I mean normally when boards
put out statements about a Founder
getting fired there they kind of they
don't say much and that was as far as
these things go pretty harsh statement
so I think we were all kind of bracing
waiting for the other shoe to drop to
find out that there was some horrible
misconduct that had occurred here and
then you know with each passing day that
hadn't come out and um and then like
like they said Sunny um Ilia put out
this mayaa so now there's no reason to
believe it even
exists um and so I think that's what so
inexplicable about this is um there
doesn't appear to have been any reason
for for this and um this is just it
seems like a case of snatching defeat
from the jaws of Victory I mean again
this is not a company in crisis this was
a company that was on its way to being
you know a centac corn uh company and
maybe a trillion dollar company one day
the company that basically I mean when
Chad gbt launched on November 30th last
year that ushered in this whole wave of
AI yes that we're seeing everyone build
on now I mean this was the next great
technology platform shift I mean all of
Silicon Valley has basically swarmed
around this and so you know this was not
a company that needed to make a change
it had no problems whatsoever it was all
kind of blue skies and up from here and
then you had this thing happened on
Friday and I think that's what's so
inexplicable well let's do a little
speculation there that's a great summary
and I think if you look at the wording
of what they said um you would think
just logically in Game Theory if they
had a real case against Sam like some
actionable item they wouldn't have gone
out with some Meek you know excuse this
this milk toast excuse that he wasn't
perfectly candid um and since they're
all getting destroyed I would think they
would have leaked the board by now to
defend themselves hey Sam did X thing
that is and listen it's fairly clear now
that if there was some Smoking Gun here
that had done something
unbelievably horrible or fraudulent
let's say it would have come out by now
so what is your theory Sachs of what
these people were thinking can I just
add one thing before David Johnson there
which is um EMT in his message made very
clear that the board hasn't even
explained to him why they fired Sam and
he wants to kick off an investigation to
understand what
happened my head's spinning yeah my
first act as new CEO will be investigate
why the last CEO was fired and why I was
hired why would you just ask that
question during your job interview yeah
what's the what do you think happened in
terms of why the board jumped the fence
went rogue and fired him what's your
best speculation Sachs just putting all
the pieces together and looking at the
chessboard well let me just first say
that I think that taking a drastic
action and then clamming up and not
explaining it is the worst possible
strategy I mean I think that if if you
take a drastic action you have to
explain it and if this was about values
if the company was going in a different
direction from a values
perspective uh than it was originally
created with and that would be all the
more reason to explain it because you
basically want to write your Manifesto
or counter man Manifesto on what the
real values of this company should be uh
but obviously they didn't do that um and
again if there's some sort of horrible
criminal misconduct I think that you
know you you gota you got to get
something out there to explain what it
is that you've done uh but again with
each passing day that there's no
explanation you begin to come to the
conclusion that there was no well
thought out reason for this and I guess
the big piece of evidence we have
towards that Sunny is that Ilia came out
with a tweet at 500 am Pacific Time
Monday morning right before markets open
uh saying I deeply regret my
participation in the board's actions I
never intended to harm open AI I love
everything we've built together and I
will do everything I can to reunite the
company what's the theory here sunny or
sax yeah I mean look I can't understand
you know how you look people can change
their minds and everyone has a right to
do it but then um to have it go through
so much public uh turmoil for the
company you know this should have been
part of the process and the only thing I
can really speculate from this is this
just shows sort of a lack of maturity of
the governance structure of the company
to basically it's the kind of thing you
want to double and triple and quadruple
check and maybe get some external folks
involved as well and and get their
opinion and so uh it's re really
disappointing I mean nice to see that he
changed and hopefully that saves things
here but disappointing in terms of how
the company was run and it kind of makes
you wonder what else is happening there
but saak what what are your thoughts my
main thought is when I saw that is um it
made me immediately think well there's
some no Smoking Gun here I mean again if
you're going to fire the founder CEO of
the next great software company in
Silicon Valley again you know 90 billion
doll company on its way to a trillion
who started this whole AI wave
everything on the surface appeared to be
as calm you know as you know as as calm
can be like no indication whatsoever
that anything's going wrong so if you're
going to fire that person out of the
blue then there has to be a really good
reason you know not just like some minor
reason like a Smoking Gun so then if you
if you retract and Rec can't and make an
apology then it indicates well there
can't have been anything there can't
just have been like a difference of
opinion over something unimportant there
had to be something factual so my
interpretation of that mayaula is that
there is nothing factual there yeah but
I've come to the conclusion saxs that
it's two things one there were they were
a little upset at Sam for doing these
deals whether it's the Johnny I you know
new phone AI phone or the new chipset
with you know maybe some investors in
Mina whatever it was that was tweaking
them and then maybe there was a little
bit of tweaking with his public profile
possibly but then I think the second
major item that was tweaking them was
the pace at which he was releasing
things and when he released agents and
apps that we talked about that's super
powerful and the the agents are a
trigger for the people who are concerned
about AI spinning out of control once
you fire up agents and they start acting
you know on that road toward autonomy
that's what makes all these doomers as
they're being called uh or deists uh get
trigged so it sounds to me like it was
I'm going with what you said you know
it's it's philosophy if it was the
second one Jason um my God man stick to
your guns I mean if you really think
this is going to end civilization then
like write a public letter explaining
what you did don't like just meekly say
I'm sorry I didn't think it through yes
it would be time to come clean yeah it's
it's probably not that I think it's it
it is just tied to focus and effort like
if you take a step back and look at
everything that's come out it's very
clear that a number of people that went
to join and you know Elon kicked this
off right started it as a nonprofit put
you know I think $40 million in and a
lot of the and one of the videos that
you know I watched over the weekend was
where he talks about recruiting Ilia and
as it was one of the hardest things he
ever did and it led to his um you know
fracturing of relationship with um
Sergey over at Google and so um that
think about what it took to recruit him
and maybe not make it about economics
because he was recruiting him into a
open uh sorry a nonprofit at that point
and you have to imagine he's brought
other people from his past research lab
and Google and other places and so when
you start seeing this commercial stuff
happening um you can you can understand
if you've been brought over and it
wasn't economic and you're starting to
see you know uh an app store emerge and
all these things happen and you want to
focus on your research and forwarding
AGI um perhaps you know that is really
what's what's causing Havoc yeah I mean
look that could be it I guess we won't
know um I guess what I'm saying is that
if the motivation here was based on
values um in the way you're saying you
know if if the board's position had been
that Sam is explaining the technology in
a way that makes us uncomfortable either
because he's explaining it for personal
gain or or you know more importantly
that they're developing these agents
that could get out of control we're
worried about AI safety and all that
kind of stuff then why would you go out
there and say it I mean put make your
argument make your case defend yourself
um don't just meekly go quiet and then
retract and recant I mean was this a
threat to civilization or not all right
business to business Founders need to
understand two things hey B2B marketing
is hard it's really hard and number two
LinkedIn ads makes it so simple for you
why is businessto business marketing so
hard well decision makers are hard to
get to they know how to hide they know
how to not get annoyed they're very very
clever about this trust me I'm one of
those decision makers and they're so
hard to identify and Target on the
internet they're stealth you can't find
them anywhere well actually you can find
them one place that's LinkedIn there are
70 million decision makers on linkon you
know as a decision maker we have to be
there and 10 million of those 70 million
are in the SE Suite Chief security
officer Chief strategy officer CEO CFO
coo wo that's like 1% of the total
audience of Executives and they have to
be on LinkedIn because that's where they
find Talent that's where they get
information that's where they get the
talented people to come to apply to jobs
at their company and that's where they
find talented people right so while
they're there you get to use LinkedIn
ads to get your message in front of the
right people this is very very simple
LinkedIn equals business business equals
LinkedIn so I want you to get started
today and you will understand very
quickly why LinkedIn is the place to be
for B2B we're going to give you $100 in
credits so you don't have to spend any
money you get to test it yourself
linkedin.com this week in startups no
spaces no dashes you type out those four
beautiful words this week in startups
and you get a $1100 terms and conditions
do
apply